KEITH: Hi, everybody.
My name is Keith [? Schafer ?].
I'm with the author's team
here at Google Los Angeles.
I'm a little too
tall for this mic.
Susan Pinker is a
developmental psychologist
who writes about social
sciences for the daily press.
She was educated at
McGill University
in the University of
Waterloo, after which she
spent 25 years in clinical
practice and teaching
psychology.
Her newspaper columns, Problem
Solving and The Business Brain
on the Neuroscience and
Behavioral Economics
of the Business
World appeared weekly
in Canada's national
newspaper "The Globe and Mail"
from 2002 to 2012.
And her radio columns currently
air monthly on the CBC.
Susan also writes opinions
and feature articles
on psychology, public policy,
education, and business
for the international press.
Her latest book is,
"The Village Effect,"
which she's going to speak
to us about right now.
Ladies and gentleman,
Susan Pinker.
[APPLAUSE]
SUSAN PINKER: Thank you, Keith.
And thank you all for
coming today, everybody.
I know you're giving up
your lunch hour, your R&R
to be here.
And I wanted to thank
also Ann Farmer who
invited me and [INAUDIBLE]
who I met on the airplane
yesterday for Montreal.
And I asked, because he was
wearing a Google sweatshirt,
if he was going to go to
the Google LA offices.
And so that's how
we know each other.
Which brings me to the
topic that I'm going
to talk to you about today.
What kind of social
contact do we all
need to be healthy, happy,
and to live long lives?
This is the question that I'm
asking in "The Village Effect."
And it's really a
question when it
comes to the science
about new evidence
from social neuroscience,
which is a fairly new field.
It's about 10 to 12 years old.
And it studies the effects
of our relationships
on our bodies and
brains and vice versa.
What's going on in
our bodies and brains
and how that affects
our relationships.
And one of the most basic
things that social neuroscience
evidence is telling us
is that our relationships
have a powerful impact
on our thinking,
our resilience, and indeed,
on how long we live.
So just a few
facts, for example.
The type of social contact
that you have influences
your physical resilience,
whether or not you catch colds
and how long you have them, how
well you fight off infection--
even how fast
malignant tumors grow.
A huge prospective study of
women with breast cancer.
There were 4,000
women in the study.
And essentially, they
looked at every aspect
of their lifestyles.
And then they sat
tight and watched
who survived their illness
by the end of 10 years.
And they discovered that
the most predictive factor
was the size of these women's
in-person social networks.
So when I refer in this
talk to social network
I mean people that
you see and interact
with face-to-face as
opposed to social media.
So in general,
people were learning
from social neuroscience
and demography
that people with active
in-person social lives
have a two- to 15-year
lifespan advantage.
And I know, given
the average age
of people who work
at Google, maybe
you're not that concerned
with how long you live.
But actually, you'll
be thinking about this
in not too long because
what we're learning
is that your social
contact is even more
powerful a predictor of
your health and longevity
than exercise or whether
or not you smoke.
So it's a hugely powerful
biological predictor
of how well you think
and remember facts
and how well you fight off
all sorts of assaults on you--
for example, dementia.
Lowest rates of
dementia among people
with the largest
in-person social networks.
And this is what I'm
calling the Village Effect.
It's a metaphor for the
kind of social contact
that we all need to
survive and to thrive.
Now how did I get
to write this book?
An intriguing fact
that I learned
from my last book, which
was about sex differences,
the science of sex differences.
And it was called
"The Sexual Paradox."
And one of the many
paradoxes that I discovered
was that everywhere in
all developed nations,
women on average live
longer than men do,
about five to seven
years longer on average.
And this isn't insignificant.
I mean as we progress,
we're all living
longer lives because of advances
in medicine among other things.
But we're just creeping along.
So as men live longer lives
women live even longer lives.
And wherever mature adults
gather-- and by mature, I
mean people in their
'50s and '60s and '70s--
you'll see that women outnumber
men about three to one.
So if you look in places like
a library, a supermarket,
tours for the retired,
pretty much-- book clubs.
I mean I talked to a
lot of book groups.
Usually women outnumber not only
three to one, but four to one.
And yesterday it was Caltech.
Women outnumbered
men about two to one,
but it was Caltech, right?
So there's a difference there.
Now a critical
factor I discovered
at the end of my
last book is that one
of the reasons
women live longer is
they have much more
extensive social lives.
They groom their social networks
throughout the lifespans.
Often, they choose work
that is more social,
or they choose to work
on teams of people
that they like and respect.
They spend a lot more time
doing what I call porch talk,
checking up on their
friends and family.
And this is not only
a statistical fact,
if you're interested, look
at my last book, "The Sexual
Paradox."
There's quite a bit about
that in this book too,
but it's also true
of my own family.
So I'm going to talk
about them for a minute.
At the end of every
workday, my grandmother
would pick up her black
rotary model telephone.
And she would check
up on all the people
who are important to her,
her friends and family.
And she wrote on a
little pad and pencil
all the people she was
going to check up with.
And despite the intimacy
of their conversations,
she address them all
formally as was standard
of the time in the 1960s.
And she addressed them all as
Mrs. [? Dubot ?], Mrs. Tarter,
Mrs. Silver, Mrs.
Cooper, Mrs. Titelbaum.
Even though they were
discussing things
like their digestive systems,
the state of their marriages,
which one of their children
was having marital problems,
et cetera.
And my mother carried
on this tradition.
This is not actually
my mother, but it
could've been my
mother, because she
spent much of my childhood
attached to the kitchen wall
by a long nine foot
telephone cord.
And also very much use the
telephone and technology
to keep in touch with
her social contacts.
And this is also true of me.
So this is what's called a
sociogram for those of you
who've never seen it.
Essentially, shows all my social
contacts with thick lines.
I'm just going to use
the one screen for ease,
for the pointer.
The thick lines show
close connections
like intimate connections.
The thin lines are
weaker connections.
And as you'll discover
later in this talk,
your weaker connections
are almost as important
as yours intimate, strong ones.
So we'll come back to that.
The circles are female.
The triangles are male.
And the dark dots are the people
who are profiled in this book.
And the reason I
made that distinction
is because this
is not only a book
about social science and
science and network science.
It's also a book about
stories of real people.
And it's also a
cautionary tale for you.
If you ever get
to know a writer,
you're going to end up in their
article or book some time.
Now getting back to how I
started to write this book,
about six years ago, I was
sitting in a dark auditorium.
And I learned an amazing fact.
There is one place
in the world where
men live as long as
women, or nearly as long.
And it's an island that is off
the southern coast of Italy.
It's a remote mountainous
area in that island
which they call a blue zone.
And it's where superlongevity,
as they call it,
is much more common
in both sexes.
So they're 10 times as many
centenarians in Sardinia
as there are in Europe
and North America.
There are six times
as many as there
are in the Italian mainland
just about 120 miles away.
And when I heard
about that I decided,
I have to go there and
find out what's happening.
I wanted to discover,
talk to the scientists,
and interview some
of the centenarians.
And I was actually making
a radio documentary
for "CBC Radio
Canada" at the time.
And you can listen to it.
If you're interested in
hearing the centenarians talk,
you can listen to it
by googling my name.
And it's called the
longevity puzzle.
And you'll be able to hear it.
Now Sardinia is an island
between Corsica and Tunisia.
It's about the size of
Switzerland and has about maybe
a quarter of its population.
So it's quite
sparsely populated.
And as I said earlier,
it's the only place
where men live as
long as women, which
is actually extraordinary.
It piqued my
curiosity, and I wanted
to find out what it
takes to live to 100,
not because I had that ambition,
but because it would give me
an idea of the biological
processes behind that event.
So let's meet some of
these centenarians.
Here we get to meet, not only
a scientist whose name is
Giovanni [? Pez ?] who is a
physician and demographer who's
devoted his career to
studying longevity,
but also because it
runs in his family.
This his uncle Pasquale
Forscone, who here is about 104
but actually lived to 110.
And he was born the year the
diesel engine was invented.
And he died the year
Facebook was founded,
2004, which is extraordinary.
And here he is.
He's walking around-- he
even went boar hunting
when he was over 100 years old.
So many people, even if
they do live to advanced
age in our society,
they're often infirm.
They can't walk.
They are often quite isolated.
And they live often
and senior's residences
where sometimes they have
around the clock nursing care.
And that was not the case there.
Now he died before I got
to Sardinia, several years
before I got there.
But I did meet some
other centenarians
who really illustrated
some of the science.
This guy's name is Giovanni.
I called him zio Giovanni,
which means uncle Giovanni,
just to give them a little bit
of the respect that was due.
And here is his niece
who he lives with.
And this is his great
niece who visited.
And I will tell you
that when I arrived,
I discovered that the whole
lifestyle there is very
different than what I knew.
For one thing, the
night I arrived,
three scientists
met me at my hotel.
And we all went out for dinner.
And everybody brought their
wives and their girlfriends.
One even brought
his brother-in-law.
And we were about 10 at
the table, 12 at the table.
And we spent a really pleasant
evening eating outdoors
and getting to know each
other, which I would say
has never happened to me
before in a scientific context
in North America.
And then when I started
to visit the centenarians,
I discovered much to
my chagrin at first
that they were never alone.
And I could never
get any clean tape
of them talking because
wherever I went,
there was always
three or four people
there-- the neighbors, nieces,
nephews, sons, daughters,
the priest, the
shopkeeper, the bar owner
who served this guy a drink
every day of his life.
It was like a virtual party.
And I quickly discovered that
being alone not only when
you're younger, say the
age that most of the people
are in this audience,
but as you age
is an impossibility there,
for better or worse.
And something else
that I discovered
is that this guy who I
talked to, as you can see,
he's not really a happy camper.
Whenever I asked
him something, he
would kind of bark back at me.
And I said, zio, what
do you think has allowed
you to live such a long life?
And there was a
pause, and he said,
nobody has to know my secrets.
And I thought, OK.
And his niece said, he
doesn't like that question.
Ask him another question.
So I said, well, do you
think it's the Cannonau?
That's the kind of red
wine that they make
in the region, dark red wine.
Do think it's the Cannonau?
And he said, nah.
I like wine a little too much.
And in general,
he was so grouchy
that he put a lie to
the notion that you
have to have positive thoughts
and a positive outlook
to live a long life.
And actually, that's
what the research shows
is that there is no evidence
that thinking positively
does anything for your
immunity, your health,
or how long you live.
It may make you
want to live longer.
It may make you feel better.
But it has nothing to do
with how healthy you are.
As you can see from
this grump here.
Yet he was still
called il tesoro
by his niece-- the treasure.
And which really surprised me.
And she treated him with
the greatest of deference.
And she even got annoyed with
me when I said, don't you
feel a little hemmed in because
you're living with a shut-in.
You're only in your mid 60s.
You never get out.
You can't leave him alone.
Isn't this hampering
your life a little bit.
And she said, you
North Americans,
you just don't
understand, do you?
This is a privilege for us.
This is our heritage.
We would never leave these
old people who are essentially
the symbol of our
community and our family
to age by themselves.
They are the center
of our community.
And it was very different
from how we treat people
as they age in North America
whereas George Burns quipped,
happiness is having a
loving close knit family
living in another city.
Most people are very mobile.
They keep up with each other
maybe with email and text,
maybe with Skype or FaceTime.
But the idea of having say
a dozen different creams
for every different part of
their parent's or uncle's
body so not to abraid their
delicate skin is probably
very unusual here.
Interestingly when I talk
about these anecdotes,
it's to enliven in the story.
But the research tells us that
even a study that came out
last month-- so it's not in
this book because this book
came out last fall.
But a study in PNAS
came out last month,
indicated that people who
are either live alone or are
socially isolated,
whether they think
so or not-- in other words,
whether they think it's OK,
or don't think it's OK, or
who say they are lonely,
have a 30% reduction in
lifespan compared to their peers
during a certain period of time.
And what's really
interesting about that to me
is that until that
study, loneliness,
or social isolation,
was considered
to be a subjective thing.
Like you weren't
socially isolated
if that's how you
wanted to live.
And if you didn't like
to interact with people,
that was considered
to be totally fine.
But actually, it does matter.
And it does affect
your immunity,
and it does affect your
happiness and your marbles.
And that was the first study
that actually demonstrated
that it's not what you think,
it is the objective fact
of how many people
live with you,
how many people do you interact
with day to day that really
counts.
Another centenarian--
here I'll show you,
I'll introduce to
you-- you could to see
that there was always a party.
There I am.
This is my daughter,
Eva, who came along
with me on the trip because
she just graduated from college
and, A, didn't know
what to do with her life
and, B, had just done an
internship at the CBC.
So she had much better
audio skills than I did.
She was the one who held
the mic and tape recorded
the centenarians.
But here is a centenarian
named Giuseppe.
He's 102 here.
Here are two of
his seven children.
These guys Angelo and
Domenico didn't live with him.
He lived by himself, but
they checked in on him
several times a day and
brought him stuff to eat.
They were very suspicious
of us, by the way,
and were very protective of him.
Now this guy was
really outgoing,
gregarious, cheerful,
loved to tell stories.
I mean it was hard
to get out of there.
And it was interesting because
he too illustrated the notion
that it's not your
personality type that
determines how long you live.
So I know I'm in
California, and I
know the new age view is that
if you are not stressed out
and you have a positive
attitude, et cetera,
and you have the right
type of personality
that all good things
will happen to you.
But actually, no.
You can be outgoing
and cheerful,
or you can be
quiet and taciturn.
These actually don't have an
effect on how long you live.
And in fact, there's
even evidence
that shows that anxiety and
persistence and perfectionism
actually adds to the length of
your life, believe it or not.
So meeting these centenarians
are just some of the stories
that I tell in this book.
And along with the science
that underpins them,
they help me understand some
little questions, such as when
am I going to die?
And how can I put that day off?
And as you will see from
some of the evidence,
it really wasn't
what I expected.
The answer isn't
really what I expected.
And I think it's
probably not going
to be what you expect in terms
of the type of lifestyle issues
that allow you to live
a long, healthy life.
So when I talk about
lifestyle issues,
I mean everything that you can
control because obviously we
can't control our genes.
But we can control
epigenetic effects.
And we can control different
things that where we live
and how we live.
And that's what I'm
going to talk about now.
I'm going to talk about a
meta-analysis by Julianne
Holt-Lunstad from Brigham
Young University, where
she essentially crunched about
158 studies of altogether
39,000 people in mid life.
Every aspect of
their lifestyle was
recorded-- how much they
drank, how much they
ate, how much they weighed,
if they were married,
if they were divorced,
who they lived with,
if they had a flu shot.
Almost everything you could
think of was documented.
And then they looked through
multiple regression analyses,
they were able to
determine over time
who was still
standing and breathing
at the end of 7 and 1/2 years.
So I mean the statistics are
complex, but the idea isn't.
It would be like if I measured
everything about everybody
in this room times
many thousands,
and then in 7 and
1/2 years check
to see who was still living.
And it's not as
preposterous as you
may think because when
I was doing research
on my first book,
I had a high school
reunion that was planned.
And this is just an anecdote.
I contacted the
organizers to see
who had died in the 30
years since I had graduated
from high school, which was more
or less correct-- maybe 25, 30
years-- because they were
having some memorial services.
And actually, the rates
of people who had died,
even some of them
before they turned 20,
mimicked exactly the
North American rates.
So it's pretty
spooky, but there are
things that you can do that
might lengthen your lifespan.
Let's look at some
of the risk factors.
Here's one that's probably
familiar to people
in California.
Whether you exercise
regularly or whether you're
a couch potato-- or I
should say screen potato.
Whether you breathe clean
air-- kind of impossible
in LA-- or you
breathe polluted air.
Whether you drink very little
or you drink a lot-- of alcohol,
I mean.
Whether you have
your hypertension
treated or you ignore it.
Whether you smoke or
not-- or smoke a lot.
Whether you have a lean
physique or your packing
on a few too many pounds.
Whether you have a full social
life or you're pretty solitary.
And what I mean by
a full social life
means getting out
and seeing people,
whether it's to have a
beer with your friends,
whether it's to play Dungeons
and Dragons, whether it's
to have a book club or
just a coffee once a week
with your best
friend at Starbucks.
It means getting out there.
It doesn't mean the
close one or two
people or maybe three people
who would probably give you
a kidney if you needed one.
I'm talking about
your larger network.
That's the high social support.
That's the difference is
those are your close contacts.
If you needed to borrow $500
who would dig into their pocket.
Whether if you've had
a heart condition,
you're doing something about it.
Of all of those, let's start
from this weakest predictor
and go to the strongest
one of how long
you will live after a span
of say 7 and 1/2 years.
Do I have any guesses
from this group
of what is the least predictive
of longevity of those lifestyle
factors?
I'm sorry, what did you say?
AUDIENCE: Alcohol.
SUSAN PINKER: Alcohol?
Any other guesses?
AUDIENCE: Clean air.
SUSAN PINKER: Clean air.
Who said that?
So any other guesses?
AUDIENCE: Exercise.
AUDIENCE: Smoking?
SUSAN PINKER: Oh!
A lot of good guesses.
Well, let's look at the bottom.
It's clean air, which is
good news for you guys.
[LAUGHTER]
SUSAN PINKER: I didn't
know, [INAUDIBLE]
if you were looking
at the window,
but the smog layer
over LA was amazing.
AUDIENCE: Well, you
had the window seat.
SUSAN PINKER:
[LAUGHTER] That's right.
So don't worry.
It might make
breathing difficult,
but it won't shorten your life.
Whether you have your
hypertension treated
is important, but not as
important as some other things.
How obese you are.
That was a huge surprise to me.
Not that predictive
of your lifespan.
Probably at the
extremes, it might be.
But certainly, in the realms
that most of us worry about,
it's irrelevant.
How much you exercise.
Huge surprise, I think, to
most of us of being predictive.
And this is for
people in middle age.
Whether or not you have
cardiac rehabilitation.
What I love is that
it's more important
that you get a flu shot
than you go to the gym.
How many of you here
have had a flu shot?
[LAUGHTER]
SUSAN PINKER: Does somebody
come to Google offices
and go around and
poke everybody?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
SUSAN PINKER: Yay, Google.
Whether you were a heavy
drinker and you quit.
smoker and you quit.
Whether you smoked
just a wee bit.
I remember when
I met my husband.
He was a smoker.
And that was kind of-- I
didn't really like that much.
And so when we travelled,
he used to buy one cigarette
at a time.
You can do that in Europe.
People will sell
you one cigarette
and a book of matches.
But gradually, he made the
segue into being a non-smoker.
Next, how much you get out
and participate face-to-face
with people in a social way.
And finally, it's
pretty much tied
for the top two
predictive factors,
your close relationships.
And what's really
interesting about that
is that our close relationships
have declined dramatically
in one generation.
So from the mid 1980s,
the General Social Survey
the United States which
does telephone interviews
across the country-- and that's
where you get most of the data
that you read about.
And at that point,
most Americans
had an average of
three people they
can confide in and depend on.
These are people
that you really trust
who are very important to you.
And now that number
is less than two.
And a lot of people,
especially men,
have one who is their
girlfriend or wife.
That means they're one person
away from having nobody at all.
So that's actually a
shocking statistic really.
That's much less
common among women.
Social integration
as I said is not
those close tight-knit people
who know a lot about you,
but more your kind of
medium range relationships.
And these are the ones
that would probably
change if you move
locations, for example.
The people you hang
out with every day.
So for example, I tell
a story in the book
about a woman who
moved on to my street
and she joined my swim team.
And we start a hangout a lot.
And we would go and walk her dog
together once or twice a week.
And as we walked
her dog together,
actually, I saw that I
lost about five pounds.
Had a lot of fun,
learned a lot about her.
And then after a few
years, she moved away.
Never saw her again.
And she was part of that--
part of my social integration.
And then, it changed.
And the research
does show that if you
don't renew your social
contacts in person,
they tend to degrade
or decay, say,
sort of like a plant
in your garden.
So this was kind of interesting.
Now it leads me to
the next question.
Here I'm asking
what kind of factors
do we need to stay healthy
and to live long lives,
but what kind of relationships
do we need to stay focused,
to learn and to stay
connected to information?
Because right now,
a lot of education
is, of course, happening
online or through Twitter.
Things are changing for
many people, not just people
your age but much younger.
Many classrooms are
becoming digital classrooms.
They're becoming-- first they
were laptop classrooms, now
they're one-to-one
tablet classrooms.
And the question that I'm
going to pose to you today
which I think is a bit-- I don't
know if it would be considered
heretical in this environment,
but I don't think it should
be-- is that not all
types of social contact
are created equal.
There are shadings
and differences
between the way there is
shadings and differences
in the type of food you eat.
Even if, say for example, a
piece of your grandmother's
lasagna is 2,000 calories
and two Oh Henry!
bars are 2,000 calories, most
of us don't confuse the two.
But very much, there's a
lot of conflation happening
between the types of ways that
we connect with other people
and especially, for
kids whose brains really
evolve to connect with people
face-to-face in a social way.
Interestingly, when I was
writing this book-- for those
of you who are considering
writing a book,
it takes a really
long time, years.
So when I started to
write this book about-- I
guess the process
started like 2009.
So that's five
years ago or more.
And people said, well,
what's your next book about?
And I said, it's
about social networks.
Everybody said, that's
really popular right now.
That's going to be a great
success because, of course,
they thought I was writing
about online platforms.
So if we look at
the type of research
that I just presented
for health and longevity,
but we look at
learning-- and here I'm
going to look at
classroom learning
because that's where most of
the research is right now.
What does academic
success hinge on?
Do I have any guesses
from the group?
What do you think is the
strongest predictor of,
besides genes.
Wealth?
OK.
We're going to strip
out genes and strip out
wealth, which you
can do if you have
a good command of statistics.
You could hold it constant.
But yeah, wealth is a
very good predictor.
Any other ideas?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SUSAN PINKER: Collaborative
learning environments?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
SUSAN PINKER:
That's interesting.
Any other guesses?
AUDIENCE: Praise?
SUSAN PINKER: Pardon me?
AUDIENCE: Praise.
SUSAN PINKER: Praise.
You guys are amazing.
No wonder you work here.
It's very, very
interesting answers.
Well, let's look at
some of the evidence.
Is it quality of parenting?
And this is a cartoon that
says, and then Winnie the Pooh
decided it was time to
check Daddy's email again.
And there are studies
that show that,
contrary to what was
thought at first,
that there is a
difference between reading
to somebody with a book,
where you turn pages,
and reading from a tablet.
And that the kids interact
with the medium and the written
word in very, very
different way--
and probably close
to the way you guys
would interact with reading
online, where you would
follow hyperlinks, for example.
If you want a definition,
you wouldn't get up
and go get a dictionary
you would just
look right on your screen.
And the difference is that
with kids, their brains
really, a lot of
them can't handle
that kind of distraction.
And they often lose the thread
of what they're reading.
But I'm getting off topic
speaking of lose the thread.
Not all learning is what
happens-- thank you very much,
15 minutes left.
What happens in the kind of
ethereal sphere of cyberspace.
Some of learning has to
do with actually talking
to other people,
having an exchange,
learning how to debate, learning
how to defend your views,
and often what is
happening in the classroom
now is that people are,
especially school boards are,
following the path
of least resistance.
Let's look at the
evidence of what
could be predictive of academic
success other than genes.
Peers, and that's where
the collaborative learning
might come in.
Single-sex schools-- is
this popular in California?
No?
That's interesting.
Popular on the east coast.
Class size, whether it's a
big class or a small class.
Whether or not that you
have a network classroom.
Whether there's a white
board, whether every child
has his own screen
or her own screen.
Whether there's a skilled
teacher running the show.
Whether they each have
their own laptops,
although most of
the time now they're
tablets as opposed to laptops.
I sort of always
wondered, what do they
do for keyboarding when
they have a tablet?
It's not very comfortable.
The parents' culture.
In other words, whether
they prize achievement,
whether they push the children,
whether they make sure children
finish a job that they started
in academic work at least.
Parents' earnings.
What of all of those do the
data tell us is most predictive?
And when you look
at meta-analyses,
essentially, when
you crunch the data
from many different studies, one
of the most predictive factors
of educational
outcomes-- and when
I talk about
educational outcomes,
I'm talking about achievement,
not things like happiness.
Was the quality of the
teacher, which is interesting.
Even the studies of educational
technology, the only ones that
have shown really a
statistically significant
difference or the ones that
have included a component
of intense teacher training.
So at the end, it's hard
to know whether it's
the technology or the
teacher training that
made a difference.
One really
interesting study that
was done by some economists at
Harvard of school-age children
crunched a whole bunch of
data of 2.5 million children,
they hadn't only
their school records,
but they had their
parent's tax returns,
so they could rule out income.
And they also had
information on things
like neighborhood,
where they lived.
So they could control for many
factors that often, really very
loosely controlled in the past.
And what they found was that
where they had areas where
a teacher boosted kids'
achievement way more than
could be expected--
in other words,
the teacher was an outlier.
He or she was that good.
If they manipulated
it and replaced
a mediocre-- or
actually, let's face
it, a bad teacher--
with that good teacher,
he or she could boost
their achievement,
but not only that had an
affect on their behavior
much later in life.
So one year with that
highly skilled teacher
between grades three eight
made it far less likely
for teenagers to become
pregnant or to make
their girlfriend pregnant.
It doesn't make them,
but it was associated
with being more likely to go
to college, more likely to go
to a good, selective
college, more
likely to earn quite
a lot more as an adult
over their lifespan.
Did I have a comment
from somebody?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
SUSAN PINKER: Total.
Not per year.
Sorry.
[LAUGHTER]
No, not per year.
I think it's an increase of
something like 1% per year,
something like that.
More likely to live in a good
neighborhood, which is amazing.
No teenager thinks about this.
So it has to do with
immeasurable effects.
And more likely to
save for retirement.
So is there really any
point to distinguishing
between this kind of childhood--
or this kind of childhood which
is what goes on right
now for many kids
in their leisure time.
Some shocking statistics
are that kids are spending--
before they get to school, the
average is four hours a day
on some sort of network device.
By the time they're school
age, it's upwards of seven.
In other words, they spend
more time in front of a screen
than they do on anything
else except sleeping.
More time than
playing with friends,
going to the park,
sports, school.
I mean it really eclipses
all their other activities.
So is there any difference
between this and this?
This is a picture of
me here playing cards
with my maternal grandparents.
This is the one who
checked up on her friends
with the black rotary phone.
Is there any difference in
the types of cognitive skills
that are required and the
types of social skills
that are required?
And I think that the research
is just now emerging.
How am I doing for time?
Ten minutes.
There's just newly
emerging FMRI research
which shows that social
interactions where there's
really a give and take
between you and somebody else
elicit different types
of brain activity.
Essentially, the way
this research was done
was, Elizabeth Redcay who
was originally from Harvard
but is now on the
west coast, she
compared two groups of subjects.
One group of
subjects, essentially,
were in the scanner and
watched canned video,
say, like YouTube--
that sort of idea.
And the second group
had the same content
but interacted about
that content socially
with somebody who was
in the room with them.
It was actually a
research assistant,
so they had a conversation
or a discussion about it.
And this subtracting
the brain activity
that happened in
the canned recording
scenario versus the interactive
scenario, these orange areas
were the differential bits.
In other words, the
brain differentially
engages those regions
when interacting
with a real social
partner as opposed
to somebody who is just
watching and listening.
And what are those regions
if you can summarize them?
They have to do with
social cognition.
Social cognition is
what psychologists often
call theory of
mind, imagining what
that other person is
thinking and feeling
and intending to do next.
That's social cognition, paying
attention to those social cues.
Where are they looking?
What does their
body language say?
Are they standing
too close to you?
Too far away from you?
Do they look bored?
Should you change your
conversation topic?
And finally, something that's
really interesting to me
is that elicits more activity
in the amygdala in areas
that signal reward,
that feels good.
You'll keep me on
track here, right?
Because otherwise I'm
going to speed ahead.
What are the signals that
are transmitted face-to-face?
This is work by Sandy
Pentland at MIT.
Mimicry and synchrony,
this is how much
you echo what's going
on with somebody else
when you're talking to them.
So if you're in a
restaurant, you lean forward,
and they lean forward.
If you lean back,
they lean back.
If your voice rises in
volume, does their voice
rise in volume?
Because essentially, we've
evolved to interact in groups.
So, much the way you
see birds fly together
as a flock or animals
pick up behavior
from another member
of the group,
we do very much the
same thing because it
signals to each other that
we're of one mind, essentially.
The activity level, how much
you move around when you talk?
The influence, how much
somebody's expressions
and movements affect
the other person's?
And finally,
consistency, meaning
how fluid is the person,
how convincing are they,
how confident are they.
And when you measure
all of these things,
this measures group cohesion
and confidence and productivity.
And if I were you, I'd
be asking, well, how
do you measure those things?
With a little device that
looks like an iPhone.
This is called the
sociometer and it
captures those honest signals.
It strips away content.
So say, unlike what is done
at Google where it picks up
content and aggregates
content, here it
strips away content and
just looks at those signals.
And using this
little device, you
can tell, for example,
how negotiations are going
and can predict with a
fair degree of accuracy
where the negotiation will go.
It predicts salary
increases of about 40%
if you're more aware of
these honest signals.
What's really
interesting about it
is that it shows how
cohesive small groups are
and the types of
signals that you
need to exchange in a small
group to be productive.
Whereas in larger
groups, for example,
if the signals are just
logistical-- little bits
and pieces of
information-- it's not
really necessary to
be there in person.
So if you confuse the
two, you risk losing
a whole rich range of data.
Now, I think I'm going
to speed ahead now
and just show you one other
really cool slide where
an experimenter,
essentially, manipulated
facial features to find out
who looks more trustworthy.
Because essentially,
in-person interactions
are hugely powerful, but they're
not always used for good.
And when you're together
with somebody face-to-face,
not only their honest
signals influence you,
but even something like their
facial features influence you.
And most politicians know this,
most scam artists know this.
And so as you move
along this array,
I'll show you-- this
is an array that they
generated of many, many
different gradations
along the way.
But essentially,
I'm just showing
you slices where there were
like 10 gradations in between.
The most honest
faces are those that
are a little feminine looking.
You see this person looks a
little bit feminine-looking
where they're arched eyebrows
as opposed to flat eyebrows,
where they have a softer,
baby-faced look and have
a cheerful demeanour.
And so people who
have that kind of face
are more easily
elected, and they're
better able to pull
the wool over our eyes.
So it's not as a face-to-face
contact is always
a unilateral good.
For example, these guys who are
Ponzi scheme scam artists had
those believable faces.
Earl Jones is a
Montrealer who scammed
the Anglo-Saxon
upper crust community
with his baby face
and his participation
in community events.
He was a hockey coach.
He was a church deacon.
He did all sorts of great
things for the community.
And people fell for him.
And you can see, there's
his arched eyebrows,
his baby face, his
smiling demeanor.
This guy, Salah
Ezzedine, essentially,
bilked the Hezbollah community
of billions of dollars--
$1.2 billion.
He built Hassan Nasrallah
who was the second in command
of Hezbollah.
And look, he's got those facial
features too-- high eyebrows.
He's a little too
hairy to look feminine,
but essentially, he has those
rounded features that convey,
you can trust me.
So why distinguish between
online and face-to-face
activity?
I'm going to skip past this.
In a world where,
essentially, people
are spending a lot of their
time online, leisure time, work
time, school time, our lives
have changed in radical ways.
And we're just now learning
some of the impact of this.
And we used to
socialize like this.
Now many of us
socialize with strangers
who could be continents
away from us.
For hours at a time, we spend
more than 520 billion minutes
a day online.
And that's just the US.
And it's probably
growing as I speak.
So at a time when
our close networks
are reducing, at a time when
loneliness has increased, when
solo living has increased,
it's worth asking the question,
really, what difference
does it make?
Because we do know the
evidence does tell us
that those with large
active in-person networks
tend to live longer, happier
lives with their minds intact.
And when I learned about
this, I was kind of
like Meg Ryan in "When
Harry Met Sally."
It was like, whatever it is,
I'll have what she's having.
And that dish is what I'm
calling, village effect.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So, could
it be that there
is some other characters
think that causes
me both to socialize
and to live longer.
Are there studies where they
coach people to socialize more
and then they
lived a bit longer?
SUSAN PINKER: There's
a couple of ways
of answering that question
like what came first.
And you can't, essentially,
in an ethical experiment,
take two matched groups
and say, OK, you guys
aren't going to
have social contact,
and you guys are
going to have a lot.
But you can do that with rats.
And when you do that with
rats, who are social mammals,
they develop 84 times the
number of malignant tumors.
It's bad for them.
And their behavior changes too.
And we also have another natural
experiment that, actually,
we're really good at in Canada.
It's called solitary
confinement.
And when you put prisoners
in solitary confinement,
essentially, they
lose their marbles.
They become ill in many ways.
And there's another-- these are
mostly perspective studies that
doesn't really answer
what you could answer
with experimental research.
But we do know one thing, which
is that a lot of the lifestyle
research that has
affected all of our lives,
say, for example, on
cigarette smoking.
It was also
correlational research.
And it's something that
has changed our lives
and changed our
environment for the better.
And finally, my last
comment about this
is that, I'm sure a
lot of us in this room
are physically active without
being Olympic athletes.
We know that this
is good for us.
And if we do a little
bit of, it will
be good for us a little bit.
And if we're great at it, it
might be marvelous for us.
But we can ape the success
of other people and say,
this works for that
population of 39,000 people.
Maybe it'll work for me.
So even without having
definitive experimental
evidence, which I think is
probably coming in the future,
we can still act on it before
it's too late essentially.
AUDIENCE: Going along to
similar of what you just said.
So there have been
studies with smoking
that show if you quit
before a certain age,
it has a huge impact on
your life expectancy.
Have there been
similar studies done
in determining if you switch
from isolation to fostering
deep social networks
by a certain age it'll
have an effect on your
life expectancy or not?
SUSAN PINKER: That's a
really good question.
I don't know of any studies
that have done that.
But it would be probably
a really interesting kind
of experiment.
But it would have to be
a natural experiment.
Because you can't
impose that on people.
But it would be an
interesting experiment
to do with lab animals,
say, for example.
Right now, they do take
rats and separate them
and have them grow up in
an isolated environment.
And that has a tremendous
impact on their cognition
and on their health.
But I wonder, they
could probably
let them grow to maturity
and then isolate them
and see what happens.
So you could find out if
there's a critical period.
I mean I don't have the
answer to that question,
but it would be really
an interesting question.
I think one of the ideas that
came to me by immersing myself
in this research
for a long time is
I see it more as how we view
climate change research.
And when I was growing up,
it was a very different
environment than we have now.
I mean you would drive along
the highway, open your window,
and throw trash out the window.
People had no idea
about the ozone layer.
People were not concerned
about pollution.
And we essentially were in
love with the automobile.
And it has taken
us 40 years or more
to realize that there have
been significant trade-offs.
And we can't get back
now what we lost.
In other words, our
cities have become donuts
with essentially people
moving to the suburbs
and we've lost
our downtown core.
Many places have no sidewalks.
We have a lot of air pollution.
There's been an impact
on people's social lives.
And I see this as a similar
kind of social experiment
where we can't wait for all
the experimental research
to start to examine the
impact, similar to, say,
the natural food movement.
A lot of people have
changed their habits
without all the
evidence being in.
But they don't want
to hedge their bets.
They want to maybe
act conservatively.
Yes.
And then I'm going
to get to you.
AUDIENCE: Maybe I
didn't quite catch it,
but are you equating there's
a long life in happiness?
Or [INAUDIBLE]?
SUSAN PINKER: Yes.
I'm not equating long
life and happiness at all.
In other words, you
can be a miserable SOB
and still live a long life.
So they're two
separate variables.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
SUSAN PINKER: Sometimes
they do, but not always.
So there's research
by actually somebody
who's not too far from here.
He's at UC Riverside.
And he more or less showed
that happiness is actually not
that critical to longevity.
I think his book is called
"The Longevity Project."
So happiness is a great
thing for other reasons.
I think it's good to be happy.
And because if you're
not happy, why would
you want to live a
long life, maybe?
I mean I think
one of the reasons
why people live long there is
there is a genetic component.
But the social component makes
them want to live a long life.
They're considered
part of the community.
Whereas if you're isolated here
and you don't talk to anybody
for weeks at a time,
maybe you wouldn't
want to live that long.
So I mean, they're
correlated in some way
but, in terms of the better
research, does not lend them,
but separates them.